en las aguas profundas que llamamos "sumideros de carbono"
porque atrapan y retienen el exceso de carbono de la atmósfera,
por lo tanto ayudan a ralentizar el calentamiento global.
A veces, estos cadáveres también terminan en las playas
proporcionando alimento a algunas especies de depredadores terrestres.
Los 200 años de caza de ballenas han sido claramente perjudiciales
y han causado una disminución de la población de ballenas
de un 60 % a un 90 %.
Claramente, el movimiento "Salvemos a las ballenas"
ha sido la mejor forma de evitar que continúe la caza comercial de ballenas
pero tenemos que volver a esta campaña.
Tenemos que abordar los problemas más modernos,
más apremiantes a los cuales se enfrentan estas ballenas
en nuestras aguas hoy.
Entre otras cosas, tenemos que dejar de arrasarlas
con buques portacontenedores cuando están en sus áreas de alimentación,
o alejarlas de las redes de pesca en las que quedan enredadas
mientras flotan en el océano.
También tenemos que aprender a contextualizar
nuestros mensajes conservacionistas
para que la gente entienda realmente el verdadero valor de estas criaturas.
Salvemos de nuevo a las ballenas,
pero esta vez, no lo hagamos solo en beneficio de ellas.
Hagámoslo también por nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)